just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one forcast
in the
[Music]
world in Lancaster County
Pennsylvania
oh that's where the that's where that's
where Amish people live yeah man I know
is crazy dud 10th favorite City
Philadelphia is in
Pennsylvania oh Benjamin Franklin City
yeah y i I knew it a man operating a
farm vehicle was arrested and accused of
driving Under the Influence just 17
minutes after he was released from
custody wow for driving Under the
Influence wow well cuz he was so
stressed out after getting arrested he
needed to drink but then he's like you
know what I'm not going to drive my car
I'm going to be safe and drive my
tractor cuz it only goes 3
mph and then the cops were like we got
to pull over this [__] [__] that's
riding on the road wait he drove a
tractor on the road a a farm vehicle yes
but wait I don't even know but it yeah
but is that not okay not if you're not
if you're drunk yeah but if you're on
your Farmland is he on the
Farmland um identified as
49-year-old uh oh they kept his name out
um he was first taken to custody on the
even of September 16th after
Pennsylvania State Police said he tried
to flee the scene of a crash in 1974
International Harvester 4000 series so
he was already on a farm vehicle and he
got into a crash and he tried to flee
going 5 miles hour in a tractor an
International Harvester that could just
be a pickup truck right if it's
International it might just be
registered as a farm vehicle by
plates waa that's deep inside baseball
up baby man could be you ruined the
image stole it I thought he was riding a
[__] lawnmower or something yeah John
Deere dude according to the crash report
the International Harvester and a 201
Toyota RAF 4 were at a stop sign when
the farm vehicle backed into the SUV and
tried to leave the area the driver of
the RAF 4 followed behind honking to try
to get the tractor operator's attention
so apparently it's a tractor oh it is a
tractor damn the driver of the tractor
the same yeah driver of the tractor
later admitted to police that he had
been drinking before getting behind the
wheel and then authorities said the
suspect was arrested processed and
released but he didn't give the officers
much time to miss him because 17 minutes
after being released from custody he was
found to be operating a tractor yet
again on the roadway well he had to
finish his work for a second DUI he had
to finish his work well so he got two
DUIs on the same day I think he's going
to lose his license and then go to jail
they let you go after one DUI that's the
thing usually well he might not have
been under the influence he was fleeing
a crime scene from a crash oh right so
he might have been under the influence
but like not to some like crazy limit
where he had to be like detained or
something so they release him from
custody that's so again gets back on
within 17 minutes and is riding it again
are you telling me this guy has a
problem you
think but wait wait where that's why
problem such a strong word do you guys
know any
alcoholics um no kind of you do
who can I should I say it yeah no I
can't say just say it I know who it is
he's a f is
boxer Oscar De La
Hoya is that who you were going to say
no I don't really know him like that I
know stories yeah I've seen that fool
[__] puking outside you know the gym
before no but I know some people that
have alcohol issues that I would rather
not say or maybe just substance abuse
who you know [__] family members and
[__] oh [__] okay you I mean they've
been through like AA and stuff D not H
yeah bro Tiff got a [__] drinking
problem there she slapped me there night
I that no hit me I was like she got
drunk and beat you up dud and I told her
I was like [__] you better not but
did you like it a little bit no actually
I didn't like it well you actually
didn't like it I was like don't [__]
hit me dog but then it's not fair cuz
she won't remember tomor I didn't get oh
did I tell you the oh I did I do have a
story about how I got bullied by a drunk
act while I was walking my dog tell you
about that you were supposed to but we
didn't say it yesterday was like a
couple weeks like last week what last
week you got bullied yeah I got [__]
bullied by some dude for like 20 minutes
while I was walking my dog what happened
you didn't use your jiujitsu n well it
was like I'll tell you about it okay I
was walking outside and I was training
my dog and some dude was like uh he
started pointing at my dog from across
the street at and he was talking to
another dog guy and he was like talking
[__] and I was like well that's weird
and then while I'm doing drills with my
pup up and down the
street he starts going like he starts
making like fake dog noises like
like that like from across the street
I'm like what the [__] this dude is
tripping and usually at that time when I
would take my dogs out I know who's out
you know what I mean like I usually see
this usual the regulars I know everybody
this guy I was like I haven't seen this
guy before so I'm walking is he homeless
not homeless oh so I'm walking he's
actually a neighbor of mine oh what yeah
crazy so I'm walking up and I start he's
on this side of the street I'm walking
up this way and he starts talking [__]
he's like
that dog is not a kid and I go okay
thank you and he goes shut your [__]
dog up and I was like okay thank you
wait your dog was barking though yeah
cuz this dude was yelling at him oh damn
and my dog has been we've been trying to
train him to be like less reactive but
part of it is just like making them
chill in like more you know Open Spaces
you know and just like relaxing expose
your therapy kind of pretty much and
then making sure that if he yells you
just go like leave it and he goes all
right I'm chilling anyway so this dude
starts yelling and he starts crossing
the street and I'm like ah [__] dude and
my dog is barking at this fool and he's
like shut your [__] dog up shut your
[__] dog up he's like do you do you
hear like do you hear your dog and I'm
like a [__] bro this [__] guy God
damn it dude and he just he kind of
starts going off and then I was like I
was like hey man you're being a little
hostile dude I was like you're coming
close to me I he's like I'm not hostile
I'm not hostile I just came across the
street and I'm like hey dude my dog's
barking at you cuz you're coming over
here I was like you're being hostile
yeah he was like probably where like
Anthony is I was like hey bro like don't
come any closer tell me truth were you
halfway like ooh it's time bro I was
like tripping I was like [__] bro my
heart was beating on my chest I was like
am I going have to [__] deal with
this dude right now [__] where's my
[__] G at yeah I know I was like [__]
dude I don't have my mouth guard yeah
and this is bro I left my phone at the
gym that night and it was like it was
like 11 it was like 10:30 and I was like
I'm going to be there in [__] 4 hours
anyway I'm just going to leave so I
didn't want to go back up so I left my
phone I'm walking by outside by myself
without my phone and uh so and Tiff's at
the house and I was like a [__] and this
and I work I'm still kind of by my house
she couldn't rescue you yeah cuz I was
like man I don't want him to see where I
live and [__] oh yeah like this
[__] and he's like where you
from where you from and I was like what
the like you like you in a gang or
something but he but you if you look at
this dude he looks like a normal guy
maybe like a Mexican dude white maybe
mixed with white but he was like skinny
ass arms big old gut and like a little
bit of a beard so I was like this
[__] is just like crazy right
now I couldn't figure out what was
happening cuz I thought he was getting
mad about me for my dog and I was like
for how I was training my dog or
whatever F he's your neighbor though
confirmed yeah so as we start going he's
like he's like I've never seen you
around here and I was like bro I'm
trying to walk my dog dude he's like
yeah all right okay okay and then he
goes I see those ears and I'm like oh
[__] dude he's like I see those ears
what does that mean I don't know what
that means so he
goes he's saying all the stuff I'm
finding out more about him and he goes
yeah I see those ears you don't think I
saw all those ears and I'm like all
right bro I'm trying to just walk my dog
so I walk my dog down the street a
little bit this gu annoying and then
this dude keeps like following me as was
I'm walking up and down the street and
I'm like [__] bro I don't want him to
see where I live so I'm trying to walk
up the street and he's like pacing up
the street and he goes I waited in today
I'm 155 lb I could take you I can take
I'm like what the [__] is going on 155
lb and I was like all right bro I was
like I bet you could I bet you could and
he's like yeah I know dude this [__] he
was say it progressively at first I was
like scared I was like what the [__] is
happening and as I was walking away I
was like dude this guy's nuts he's just
crazy the cool part of this is the only
time I think I'm like I like at way oh
yeah cuz you can report them hey you
have someone that's unruly and then
they'll just hit send a letter to their
house so this gu he's following me up
the street and he's like yeah I can take
you would you like 180 180 and I'm like
oh my God pleas damn dude and he keeps
going up uh and then I stopped I stopped
seeing her for a little bit and then I
start walking back down and he's like
yeah I'm [__] watching you I'm
[__] watching oh my god dude and it
this is like this is like [__] 20
minutes like this is going on for 20
minutes and he keeps saying all that
[__] and then um I was walking you keep
walking down and then back up cuz you
walk yeah cuz I'm like dude let this
[__] I was just like and I kind of was
like what the [__] else is he going to
say so he's like you wish you wish he
would [__] touch you no I I really
didn't I really didn't did you want to
like just tie your dog up and like yo
like what do you want to do let's just
do what you want to do right now part of
me knew what the right answer was was
just [__] don't say anything and just
keep walking that to me that in my head
I was like that's the right thing to do
you're very controlled man get even
better I'm walking back to my house and
I'm like [__] it I'm should have walked
towards my house and he's like yeah go
back to your house with your boyfriend
you f word he goes you you know you
bundle of sticks and I'm like with this
bro it it made me laugh though it made
me laugh uh Joe what's the f word friend
yeah dude he call me f oh F Double G's
Double G's dude R's with maggot and then
I and I I laughed and I was like damn
bro you're drunk I just I I I don't know
why I said that but I said that and he's
like oh actually I'm not drunk I'm
completely
sober he said bro he said it like that
and he got like mad like I'm actually
completely sober and I'm like all right
dude I shouldn't have said anything I'm
should keep walking and then he's like
he's like I know where you live go back
to your house in the back you your f
word ass house that's what he's saiding
bro and he's saying a lot more too but
like this is the condensed version and
I'm like oh my God bro this is [__]
so crazy so I I walked towards a house
that like is not my house and then he
walked up and he's like I live [__]
right here and it was like the apartment
building and I was like oh [__] this is
[__] nuts and then the next couple
days I'm like looking out for this dude
I'm like when the [__] I've never seen
this dude yeah bro he was being hella
weird I haven't seen him again and then
one day I'm walking during the day with
Tiff and I'm like babe that's him right
there and he just [__] walking all
normal and I'm like oh my god dude this
guy he didn't even like look at me he
didn't even know he didn't even [__]
know dude and he was like he was like
threatening my dog at some point he's
like I'll [__] take care of your dog
you think he had mental issues I for
sure he might have been not on his meds
I think that [__] was just drunk
and but I also don't know if he even saw
me across the street he just was like he
just looked completely normal but then
the other night he was just like pacing
up and down the street he was trying to
like challenge me to like grappling he's
like yo I'm on the mats bro it was so
crazy what is happening that but he
passed you by like he never even seen
you before yeah but he was across the
street so I don't know if he even saw me
does he live but I but I saw and I was
watching this [__] and I and he
walked into the apartment complex and I
was like this [__] that must
have ruined her night though oh bro I
woke up like cuz I'd be so [__] riled
up like God damn what the [__] I woke up
at like 2: a.m. and just like [__] I
couldn't sleep P just like what the [__]
and it ruined my it ruined my sleep that
night ruin my sleep but it was a trip
though I don't know what I wanted to
like even but it in my head I was like
this guy's going to kick my [__] ass
at one point I told him I was like you
better stop following me I'm going to
call the cops I told him you said that
yeah I did say that and then he did he
didn't he didn't listen he's like oh I
[__] wish you would call the cops
that's when it started getting [__]
hilarious where he was like just being
hella funny dude what the thing is like
Nick you always double question yourself
but as soon as this dude throws hands
like you are going to murder this dude
no but you know what it is though killed
him yeah part of me was like afterwards
I did get mad cuz I was like damn the
level of like disrespect this dude came
up to me and was just talking why are
so [__] he told you his weight class bro
I was like you 155 I was like I smash
you brother I smash you but no it was a
trip cuz I was fired up I was like
scared I was feeling all kinds of things
but like as it went on longer I was like
oh I'm just this is fine I'll be okay
he's just a crazy dude yeah and I was
like I could talk to I can call the
neighbor and be like yo this dude's
bugging me bro I I'll tell I'll tell the
I'll tell the I'll tell on them dud I'll
call the cops you should though because
you Tiff is there
too no yeah she was at the house she
didn't even know yeah that's good cuz
you don't want to escalate you guys are
neighbors I don't want him to see who
Tiff is you don't want to turn into a
thing yeah but I was like if this dude
comes up to me I'm going to call him if
you're living that close to an unstable
[__] nutcase yeah it is a little bit
unsettling n it was weird bro I was like
we don't have that in Vegas I just you
know oh yeah not in Vegas at all
everyone's totally fine there that
doesn't happen in
[Music]
Vegas